welcoming the crowd favorite
matthew b cox good evening matt
what's up thanks for coming back to the
show
we oh look what we've got here today
some studio pins
so matt archie what yes
are we going to talk about today what is
the title of your new book
all right
i'm glad you asked it's it's insanity
the bizarre story of a bipolar
megalomaniacs
insane plan for total world domination i
think i went a little overboard on the
subtitle
but you know no it's perfect i know it
is you could do
very well you think i could have written
the yeah a small paragraph so this is
one of your most popular stories it's a
fan favorite
about the one and only frank amadeo
the bipolar schizophrenic sociopath
megalomaniac
with with through sociopath you said
sociopath
okay what's what's the actual title for
him
um he is a rapid cycling he's an access
one rapid cycling bipolar with features
of schizophrenia
and wha how did you first meet this guy
um
he was he came into the prison
i don't know when it was 2009
or not yeah 2009 or 10 yeah 2009
in the low and he was all drugged up for
like a year or so
took him like a year to convince the
staff to take him off of the psycho
psychotropic
psychotropic the meds yeah
and they took him off the meds which
helped him kind of clear up his thinking
and he started fighting his case of
course by the time they took him off his
meds
he was time barred from actually being
able to fight
his uh his conviction because you only
have one year
so by the time they take him off the
meds and he's able to actually kind of
comprehend what's going on yeah it's
been past a year
and he it's too late to start fighting
your case you only have a year
so anyway he ends up fighting
he ends up fighting a ton of uh other
inmates cases
and my case is one of the cases that he
fought he's like the go-to lawyer for
all the inmates at goldman yeah
he was a real trained lawyer he's a real
lawyer is he an actual is he a good
lawyer he's [ __ ] he's an amazing
lawyer
i'm serious what do you mean how much
time did he get you knocked off
12 years that they did that they didn't
want to give me
that they absolutely didn't want to give
me and i talked to
multiple lawyers on the street that said
you don't have a shot
there's nothing you can do and yet he
managed to get file 2255s
get the court to appoint me to attorneys
both attorneys flew down
and said you know what are you doing you
know
they were like oh you wrote this motion
but you need to take the police you need
to take who else's case did he work that
he got a bunch of time off of
a ton of guy i mean i got a i got a list
of guys in the book what about devaroli
uh no no dev rolly no no no dev rolly
got six years he got
two four-year terms okay and it was
actually part of it
from people listening who don't know who
he is he's the guy that the movie war
dogs is based off of
jonah hill jonah hill yeah jonah hill
made deborah look
and you were cuddling you were hanging
out with him in prison yes i wrote i
wrote a
memoir for i wrote devaroli's memoir
which is called
once a gun runner and we're talking to
him he's he might come on the show he
might be he might be a guest soon
he may we keep he's scared he's scared
of the being in the in the
in the limelight he is he doesn't want
to laugh like like jonah hill does in
that movie
did you meet you met him oh yeah he
spent time
never showed up on time not one time did
he ever show up
never never you couldn't let him walk
off or
like hey i'll be back in 20 minutes
never see him again
gotta go hunt him down he'd turn around
you'd walk in his cell and turn around
and look at you go oh [ __ ]
oh oh and then he all right i'm coming
i'm coming
did you i don't know he doesn't i don't
remember how jonah hill laughed but
deborah really laughed
that's a real high-pitched laugh it was
like really weird
no he that dev rolly laughs like just
like in your face like
i mean just like he's he's crazy he's
crazy
it's great what are his uh
conditions does he have any of these
these conditions that the emperor has
he's bipolar
he's bipolar bipolar narcissistic
arrogant pretty much pretty much the
same stuff i have but
uh so how long have you worked on this
book about uh frank amadeo the emperor
i've been writing and why do you call
him the emperor
all right let me can i give you you want
me to give this one you told me i want
to know i want to know why
why everyone calls him the emperor
because since he has been a
in his teens he has believed that he's
hearing the voice of god
tell him he is preordained to be emperor
of the world
now lots of people think that lots of
people say that right not lots of people
what am i saying lots of people
lots of homeless people say that like
crazy people say that the difference is
you know he graduates high school he
goes on to college
he ends up getting a law degree he
becomes a venture capitalist
he gets he according to the irs he had
over
70 no irs this is the fbi according to
the fbi
he has over 70 companies
he committed a major fraud and he was
hiring
they said he has hired retired fbi
agents irs agents and secret service
agents to work for him
um he had several like small black
water style companies uh he puts this
whole thing together
his whole purpose for building this
whole conglomerate
is to ultimately take over the world
he tried to buy fighter jets i got
pictures of him with the fighter jets
i've got
oh not just look it's not just that bro
jesus christ look at this
this dude's gnarly this is i'm looking
at pictures of this
goofy fat man frank amadeo standing next
to a fighter jet
with his foot up on the ladder like he's
posing next to a [ __ ] sports car
and this hit the seat one of the other
ceos of his company is is the guy that's
sitting in the cockpit
they fly and i talk about it they fly in
like two two airplanes i forget what
that was an f-18 or f-22 or something
they fly him in but he's actually trying
to buy
um a like a squadron like two dozen
f-14s and f-15s how much are those
planes
i don't know the total purchase was like
60 uh
okay we're gonna we're not going to
answer that um the total purchase
of the planes was uh 60 million
so i don't know what a used f-15 goes
for but if it's 30 years old and that
you know the technology is 30 year old
technology but they're still flying all
over the
middle east and in africa and yeah and
um you know
all over europe they're still you know
um what is it israel still
flying f-15s f-16s he's trying to buy
f-14s and f-15s did frank amadeu give
you permission to publish this book
about him
um yeah he did i mean he participated
in the writing of the book he
participated in the writing does he know
you published it
i don't know if he knows i if i don't
know if he knows i published it so you
think it's better to ask it's just that
it's like
ask for forgiveness instead of for
permission type deal
with the book i don't i don't oh you
don't need permission to publish it
how do i need a permission you
participated you knew i was about him
right
i was writing a book you gave me
permission you knew i was writing a book
about you participated
if you talked to a reporter and suddenly
two weeks later
you're there's an article about you
talking to the reporter are you gonna
say it's freedom of speech yeah but i
just feel like it'd be so
scary to paul you know you said how good
of a [ __ ] lawyer he is he got 12
years off your sentence
like don't [ __ ] with a guy that's that
good of a lawyer because my god
listen i don't know it just seems like a
sketchy thing to do
it seems like hey maybe that could be
pretty
i feel pretty confident about the
constitution the united states giving me
permission
though yeah pretty sure okay so if you
were in public
and you videoed someone two guys getting
into a fight and you put it on youtube
are you allowed to do that
yeah you are you are right he actively
participated
actively participating in the book um
i mean told me gave me all of this
information he gave me all this
what is all this information you have
over here what is all this paperwork i
mean this is an f this is fbi
this is an fbi 302 talks about his
companies talks about how he's hiring
all these guys
let's see what is this
what is this i don't know man i didn't
really have time oh these are articles
about the congo where he was um
when he tried to take he tried to do a
try to pull off a political coup
in the congo by backing a political
candidate this is uh
an article in the uh herald tribune this
is one from the new york times
wow this is the new york times this is
one from
world news you made it now nbc this is
oh listen to this so i looked up private
military
2006 this new york times article was
from
32 charged in coupe plot being sent home
congo said it was deporting 32
foreigners including three americans
that are charged last week with planning
a
coup before national elections in july
can you read it like michael barbaro
who's michael babaro the guy from the
daily oh
no i can't do that i'm not even going to
try to do that
a coupe before national elections in
july saying it would have been
it would have taken too long to
prosecute them officials said the men
who also included 10 nigerians 19 south
africans
worked as security guards and were found
with weapons the americans employer
aqmi strategy corp of orlando florida
acme accepted
this company strategy corp of orlando
florida said they were providing
security
and campaign counseling for a candidate
in the elections and we're not carrying
any weapons a united nations spokesman
of
kinshasa the capital
is that the capital of the congo has
said the organization
organization believes the arrests are an
attempt at political
manipulation before the elections all
right so interesting you can see that
acme corporation that's his company
frank amadeo okay
it was actually called acme corporation
acme that's spelled aqmi
and blackwater and all those right yeah
so right here
and this is like this is this guy from
blackwater the chairman of blackwater
and this is everything
this is his company right here is acme
strategy court that's frank's company
wow same company so i mean so he had a
bunch of
anyway look the point is is that he was
a lawyer
he actually was disbarred
what's wrong oh nothing what the [ __ ] i
don't know what's the deal i don't know
what the deal what's going on nothing i
was just looking at him
i can hear a mouth breathing from here i
mean i i really only do like a a short
half chapter or chapter on his childhood
him becoming they try uh tried to be re
the cia tried to recruit him did i tell
you i interviewed a guy from the cia
yeah i tried to give you the i tried to
get you to call him and take bring him
on the podcast
oh he's a cia guy yep i remember him so
i interviewed a cia guy
all about his really yeah oh it's great
what'd the cia
guy have to say the guy was basically
saying because amadeo said when he was
about to graduate law school the cia
came to him
and they were they were basically in the
law school in emory and they were
asking guy people lawyers are about to
be lawyers that they would ask him to um
fill out
you know to take tests takes tests to
see if they want to be a cia agent
he took it and they came back and they
said look you know we want to offer you
a job they offered him a job
but amadeo before amadeo graduated his
father came down with uh
esophagus cancer like throat cancer and
so he
he couldn't do it he had to like stay
and take care of his father so he never
ended up doing it
he ended up getting a law degree he
became a bankruptcy attorney
he eventually ended up losing his
license
you know look he's bipolar so he has
fits he has basically
he'll go through he'll be kicking ass
for eight months or a year yeah
go into a deep deep depression for four
or five days or a week and can't even
get out of bed
really and the thing is he's he's also
this is ridiculous it's gonna sound
silly
he's hypersensitive to uh caffeine so he
like i would sit there and you you're
talking to him he would drink a six pack
of ca of coke i probably probably drink
40 or 50 cokes a day or pepsi's a day in
prison
constantly drinking him to try and
elevate himself so that he didn't
slip into a depression like a mood
stabilizer
so yeah but isn't that like the opposite
of a mood stabilizer because you're just
gonna be [ __ ] jacked on sugar and
then you're just gonna crack
i mean maybe but the fact is is he's
he's bipolar so who knows
he's up you understand look we would be
i'm gonna give you an example of what
it's like being around him maybe he's
just like trying to
fight through the depression part with
the sugar right so he can feel it coming
on so he drinks four or five of these
things and it
kicks them back up okay okay so
literally like the guy is brilliant
right he's doing all this legal work in
prison
but i mean but i'm just gonna give an
example of what it's like being around
him
okay just so that you understand that
that
so we're all sitting at stonehenge which
was this area
in uh coleman we call the stonehenge
we're all sitting around a concrete
picnic table
talking about wall work talking to your
mic talking about law work
and suddenly me pete donovan
frank's there they're all talking about
law work and i'm just sitting there you
know listening
and donovan says something and all of a
sudden frank goes
no no that's not gonna stand absolutely
not
no i'm not gonna let that hap when my
legions
march on washington we will burn the
constitution
and the president will bow it up my feet
and he sits there for a second and
nobody says [ __ ] everybody just sits
there
and he goes
okay we need to do a johnson motion so
i'm going to need a 2255 for him
and uh okay frank i'll get you the
twenty-five all right do you need the
right yeah there's there's some go ask
thomas in in b3 okay i'll go right now
and take it and you walk off
and it never happened right and nobody
says [ __ ]